hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
amid a pandemic much of the discussion
surrounding the 2020 presidential
election
has been focusing on the coronavirus and
its impact on the u.s economy
but are voters taking their eye off the
ball when it comes to foreign policy
president trump's former national
security adviser retired general h.r
mcmaster
discusses what he considers to be some
of the biggest threats from abroad
and explains why he fears the
politicization of the u.s military
could undermine national security
supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg making history
even after her death becoming the first
woman
to ever lie in state at the u.s capitol
christopher scalia's son of the late
supreme court justice antonin scalia
opens up about his father's unlikely
relationship with justice ginsburg
and the newly published collection of
his father's writings
titled the essential scalia plus
commentary by fox nation host
tom chalu the fox news rundown is a
daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player by going to
foxnewspodcast.com
i'm greg jarrett i'm shannon bream i'm
steve ducey and this
is the fox news rundown
friday september 25th 2020
i'm lisa brady as americans cast their
votes this fall
poll after poll finds coronavirus and
the economy as top concerns
but should voters be giving more thought
to other global issues
we are lucky we live in a democracy we
can demand a better foreign policy
from our elected officials i'm chris
foster
the last fight over a supreme court seat
this heated was after justice antoine
scalia died
his son christopher says his father in
ruth bader ginsburg saw past their own
differences
you know despite all their differences
and and um
all the the many things they disagreed
about um
uh they they had a wonderful friendship
and they were able to kind of focus on
the
the things they had in common and i'm
tom chalu
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
like so many things with president trump
his approach on the world stage
often doesn't follow traditional norms
as president
i have rejected the failed approaches of
the past
and i am proudly putting america first
just as
you should be putting your countries
first that's okay
during that speech to the u.n general
assembly on tuesday
he also laid into china and the world
health organization again
over their handling of coronavirus there
have been some historic milestones in
the trump era
including the first recognition of
israel by any arab nations
in a quarter century this day is a pivot
of history it heralds a new
dawn of peace that white house signing
ceremony with the israeli prime minister
the uae in bahrain
is now the backdrop for a campaign ad
but in an
open letter to america nearly 500
retired and former military and
government officials
are now backing joe biden for president
writing that he has the character
principles and wisdom necessary to
address a world on fire
dozens of former national security
officials who served in republican
administrations
have also endorsed biden calling
president trump unfit to serve
well lisa i respect anybody's right to
you know to voice their opinion to sign
these kinds of
petitions and letters but it's just not
the role i think is appropriate for me
h.r mcmaster was president trump's
second national security adviser when he
was still a lieutenant general in the
army
he's now a senior fellow at stanford
university and author of a new book
battlegrounds the fight to defend the
free world
i served in our army for 34 years 38
years
including west point i went to west
point when i was 17. and you know
i decided that i would follow george
marshall's example
and not vote as a way to keep the
military
studiously out of politics and and i
think in retirement
you know i'm thinking about voting
obviously but i think that i i don't
want to get mired in
partisan politics and i don't even as an
a retired you know
washed up general i i don't want to in
any way
contribute to the military becoming
involved in
in partisan politics well let's talk
foreign policy
because that is the focus of your new
book some critics have
said for a long time that this president
doesn't really have
a foreign policy doctrine if you will
but is that
something a president needs to have an
overarching
well i think there is an overarching
document that the administration
published in december 2017
and and uh i worked with members of the
national security council staff and with
the president to produce
the first national security strategy
that was ever published in the first
year of a presidency which
every administration is supposed to do
but none of them have been able to pull
it off and
and there are some very significant
shifts
in u.s foreign policy in that document
many of which i think were long overdue
and in particular
the shift from you know what some people
would call the you know the cooperate
and engage
approach to china to to competition with
china and recognizing
the rivalry we and the free world have
with the chinese communist party
speaking of china
i mean there was a recent pentagon
report that says china's
navy is now the largest in the world
there's ongoing concern about chinese
espionage including
attempted election interference now
president xi
just announced he wants to crack down on
china's greenhouse gas emissions i mean
is the u.s concerned enough about the
rise of china
in the world they seem to be going full
steam ahead despite
human rights issues right and
we all want china to rise right john
what we want
the chinese people to continue to
succeed but the problem is the chinese
people are subjugated
to the chinese communist party who as a
right in battlegrounds
is really determined determined to
extend and tighten
its exclusive grip on power and thereby
to deny the chinese people a say in how
they're governed
and that is coupled now with this very
aggressive agenda internationally
in which they're trying to export their
authoritarian and mercantilist model
in a way that severely disadvantages not
only america
but but the free world and so it's
really important i think now
to confront the chinese communist party
and as you mentioned the broad range of
activities they're engaged in
under these very sophisticated
strategies for example made in china
2025
includes a sustained campaign of
industrial espionage
to steal sensitive technologies and
intellectual property
and and in what has been the largest
transfer of wealth
in human history in connection with
china's ability to do that
so we have to defend ourselves we have
to make ourselves better
what about in other parts of the world i
mean there are so many aspects
to to foreign policy your book is
critical of multiple
administrations over the past quarter
century
so what besides maybe not focusing
enough on china
what else has america been doing wrong
if you will
in in your view right well what we did
is we we based i think our foreign
policy on
on what i call in battlegrounds
strategic narcissism and this is a
tendency to define the world
only in relation to us and to not
recognize
the the influence the the control the
the authorship over the future
that others have is particularly our
adversaries and
and our rivals so in many ways our
policies and our strategies have been
based on
the world as we'd like it to be rather
than the way it really is and so we
haven't competed
we've vacated key arenas of competition
and i described how this emotional
impetus behind our policy shifted
from overconfidence and complacency in
the 1990s
to to really pessimism and almost
resignation
in in the 2000s so what we need now is
we need to view these complex problems
really in a way that allows us to
understand them better
on their own terms and so each part of
the book really is based on an effort
to to understand how the past produced
the present
as the first step in making a projection
into the future
and determining what we need to do to
advance and protect our interests
so what i'm hoping to do is i hope that
this book will help inform
americans about the greatest challenges
generate discussion
and then we are lucky we live in a
democracy we can demand a better foreign
policy
from our elected officials i know this
isn't
a tell-all book about working for the
trump administration
there have been a string of those though
many of them very unflattering and
highly critical of this president does
that
surprise you that so many people have
come out and done that
after leaving the administration well it
does
it does surprise me it i mean i thought
i'm just not going to write a book like
that obviously i mean i i just don't
know what good it would do
and to write another tell-all or palace
intrigue book i wanted to write
something
more substantive and i hope useful to to
readers
and and you know of course in my
position in particular as national
security advisor
you're the person who has the president
as his or her only client
you're in a position of privilege and
trust if you violate that trust what i'm
concerned about
is not only is it dangerous to our
security to to write a tell-all from
that position
but also it would shake the confidence
in any future president and
can i trust my national security advisor
and and you know i
i think it's important as a serving
military officer in particular too to to
not violate that trust and confidence
now as you may know if you've looked at
the book i mean i'm very critical of
president trump's policies in certain
areas
i give them credit for i mean i think
important achievements in foreign policy
as well
uh so it's not that the book is
uncritical it's just that i think
i hope people will judge the book to not
be petty
and to in fact be be useful and
constructive
what do you think is the the top foreign
policy
issue that he got right and the one that
he got the most wrong
well i think on on on china it's he got
it he got it right i mean i think it was
the most significant shift in u.s
foreign policy
at least since the end of the end of the
cold war and it was and it was long
overdue
i think what the what the president got
wrong and is it but it reflects really a
sentiment
across our country is is the is this
really just
desire to disengage from complex
challenges overseas
and and to believe that that
disengagement is an unmitigated good
and this is really the afghanistan
policy in particular in which we're
we seem to be partnering with the
taliban against the afghan government i
just don't understand that i think that
we've created in our minds the enemy we
would like in afghanistan
and this is this is going to be lead to
i think a significant setback in
in our security and and uh and there's a
similar sort of drive to just disengages
an end and of itself
in the middle east as well and hey we
don't need like hundreds of thousands of
troops in the region
but what we need to do is we need to
support those who are bearing the brunt
of those fights against jihadist
terrorists
or limiting iranian influence in the
case of the middle east so i just think
that
in some ways the trump administration is
replicating
some of the flaws in the obama
administration's approach which is to
view
disengagement from you know so-called
endless wars
as an unmitigated good it's worth
pointing out your wars don't end when
one side decides to leave
do you think foreign policy is something
that voters in general
should care more about
yes yes yes and and uh and i i think
that there's there's a tendency for us
to think okay
hey it's time for introspection now
right we're we're
we're suffering this triple crisis of of
cover 19
the recession associated with proven 19.
you know the divisions in our society
laid bare by george floyd's murder and
and other developments since then you
know the the disappointment and
inequality of opportunity in the country
the debates we're having about
about you know you know racial uh
justice and so forth
but if we draw back to our shores and we
become
exclusively introspective these crucial
challenges don't stay away from us right
and i think
i think the the analogy to use is covet
19 itself right pandemics are best dealt
with
at the source before they become a
pandemic you can say the same i think of
jihadist terrorism
you can see it say the same of deterring
revisionist powers on the eurasian
landmass like china and russia
i have to ask what you what do you think
about our country's response
to the pandemic even from a national
security or
or foreign policy standpoint are you
concerned about it
well i think what's most important is
that we learn from the shortcomings
and and we make adjustments i think that
the government has done that
and i think the untold story is what the
private sector has done
to adapt uh to to this crisis now we we
had some some significant shortcomings
right there there are really three key
ways to deal with a pandemic to cope
with the potential of a pandemic or a
biomedical emergency
one is as i mentioned to try to try to
stop it at source well thanks to the
chinese communist party there's
suppression of the
of of the information relevant to the to
the pandemic so the world could respond
we couldn't do that the second is to is
to mobilize a biomedical response
we have to recognize hey we're a federal
system our health care system is a
combination of public and private
and i think the biggest shortfalls were
shortfalls in coordination
and then also shortfalls in in
preparation across those
levels of government and between the
public and private sector for too many
years
we we biased decisions in favor of
efficiency
and just-in-time delivery of things like
personal protective equipment
and so our supply chains were very
vulnerable we didn't have the stocks in
place okay we can learn
we can learn from that and then the
third key element area of response is
innovation biomedical innovation with
therapies and of course
a vaccine i think that's going to wind
up being a good news story i mean i
think that
there have been significant investments
in this area over time
and i think those are going to pay off
when we look back
when we look back on this crisis but
what's really important is for us to try
to ring
the partisan politics out of this
coveted experience and
learn the real lessons the book is
called
battlegrounds the fight to defend the
free world
former national security advisor h.r
mcmaster
thank you so much sir for your time lisa
thank you so much pleasure to be with
you
this is tom chalu with your fox news
commentary coming up
ruth bader ginsburg lies in the state of
the capitol today the first woman ever
given that honor in the first supreme
court justice since william
howard taft and he'd also been the
president justice ginsburg's casket was
at the court for two days for people to
pay their respects including president
trump and the first lady
booed when they got there
[Applause]
the president has had nice things to say
about justice ginsburg since her death
you may agree you may not disagree with
her but
she was an inspiration to a tremendous
number of people
i say all americans and now he says it's
his job to fill that seat on the court
i think it's very important that we have
nine justices
and i think the system is going to go
very quickly the president plans to
announce his nominee tomorrow
joe biden and a lot of other democrats
say he should fill that seat if he wins
the election in light of republicans
blocking president obama from filling a
seat
in an election year it's wrong it's an
abuse of power
the seat president obama would have
filled antonin scalias
went to neil gorsuch instead of merrick
garland for all the fighting there's
been over justices scalia and ginsburg
in life they were very good friends
people always find it surprising that
they were such good friends
christopher scalia is the eighth of
antonin scalia's nine children there's a
new collection published of his father's
writing called the essential scalia
their friendship went back
really to the uh early 80s when they
were
judges together on the dc circuit court
of appeals
which is kind of like the the second
most important court in the country
and they uh they had a good working
relationship
that which really started back then they
would
uh help each other revise their drafts
and their their opinions that
apparently the other judges on that
court really didn't like
getting advice about their writing and
how to improve the clarity of what they
were writing and the force of their
arguments but
justice ginsburg liked getting and
receiving that kind of advice
and so did my dad and they formed what
he called a mutual improvement society
uh during their time on the court there
and um
and they they uh had other things in
common
they were they had similar backgrounds
and that they were both uh
new yorkers grew up in in new york
around the same time different boroughs
but
around the same time and shared a love
of
opera good wine
eating good food both of their spouses
were excellent cooks
uh marty ginsburg in particular was kind
of a legendary cook who would
put together wonderful meals every new
year's eve and they would celebrate new
year's every
every year as well so you know despite
all their differences and
and um all the the many things they
disagreed about including a number of
opinions in this collection
um uh they they had a wonderful
friendship and we
were able to kind of focus on the the
things they had in common
yeah your dad and justice ginsburg i i
don't know the statistics on how often
they concurred or dissented on cases but
i'd imagine that they disagreed
maybe as much as any two recent justices
have am i right
yeah i think that's that sounds right i
don't know the statistics either
i think people would be surprised by how
often they agreed with each other
but on the the real hot button cultural
cases they often disagreed
um you know one of her most important or
most famous opinions
was uh the virginia military institute
uh case from the mid 90s and uh
my my father wrote a dissent
uh to that case which is in this
collection
the essential scalia and it was uh he
actually gave her
the draft of that descent a little bit
earlier than one usually does just so
that she would have more time to kind of
deal with it and grapple grapple with
his arguments um and
and uh yeah it's some of his most uh
stinging dissents were were in response
to
opinions she didn't necessarily write
but but joined
and i think that's probably true vice
versa yeah tell the story about the
big bouquet of roses she got from him
yeah well my dad would get her roses for
her birthday
and i guess the uh
i think the last time he did that so the
year before he died
one of the editors of the essential
scalia judge jeffrey sutton was visiting
my father in chambers on
on justice ginsburg's birthday and he
saw that my dad had
two dozen roses for justice ginsburg and
uh judge sutton started teasing dad
saying you know i haven't even gotten my
wife two dozen roses over the course of
our entire marriage
um why would you do this and besides
when was the last time she sided with
you
on a really important 5-4 decision uh
you know he's poking fun
you know not not really being serious
but my dad gave a serious answer which
was
some things are more important than
votes this is i think
i just kind of a great encapsulation of
their
of their relationship and of their
friendship they had
they had uh very different opinions
of uh politics and and of their jobs as
as judges and of what laws meant and
what the constitution meant
but uh how they voted
wasn't the biggest factor in their
relationship it wasn't that
those opinions didn't matter and it
wasn't that they compromised their
beliefs for each other
but they didn't let those very strongly
held beliefs
undermine their very deep friendship the
new collection of supreme court justice
antonin scalia is writing sort of like a
greatest hits album it's opinions and
other writing about the law and the
constitution again called
the essential scalia this is uh really
just a collection of
his greatest legal writings opinions
speeches essays and they you know
collected together give a really good
uh sense of why exactly he was
such a significant um supreme court
justice
uh and it's it's there you know having
it in one collection really makes it
tangible for anybody to to understand
that
well just as a legal reference work
you've got to think it's going to end up
being
bought by or for a lot of lawyers and
judges
yeah no absolutely and law students i
hope uh
you know that he he wrote clearly he
wrote
uh and he had so many memorable phrases
and his opinions his logic was so strong
and convincing that uh people just kind
of they often went to his opinions first
and so it's good for people to kind of
have that as a resource to to keep going
to those opinions even
you know even after his passing i mean
it's also besides
the legal community it's also like you
said it's very readable even for
non-lawyers for just a general interest
audience who might
he was just simply a very very good
writer yeah that's exactly right he
uh he wrote for i guess we would now
call it
out of transparency you know even when
he was writing uh
supreme court opinions he understood uh
that they should be uh understood
themselves uh
by everyday citizens not just you know
legal eagles and people with
legal degrees he i mean a kind of a
recurring theme of his opinions
is that people should know what the
court courts are doing and people
that the court should not use cert power
that properly belongs to the people
and i think that kind of reverence for
um the democratic order is
is kind of manifest in his in the
clarity
of his writing a lot of times if if he
had a vote a personal vote on how a case
would turn out it may or may not a lot
of times it did align with how he
ruled but sometimes it probably wouldn't
have right yeah i think that's true and
that that's especially true
in um one example is uh
when he sided with the majority in a
flag burning case
the majority ruled that um it was
constitutional sorry burning the flag
was
constitutionally protected speech under
the first amendment so prohibiting that
in the state law was unconstitutional
and my father often explained that he
did not like
um the idea of flag burning if he were a
king he would ban
it but it clearly to him falls under
uh the protection of the protection of
the first amendment
and a lot of conservatives to this day
do not like that opinion
um but my father thought the
constitution was clear about that
there are many examples in this
collection the essential scalia of
instances in which he
stands up for the rights of the accused
um defendants rights there's a famous
case in here where
uh it's search and seizure cases as well
there are a couple of those in here
where he just thought
you know the the the police did not have
authority for example to use
um scans of uh houses
to to identify mayoral who was growing
marijuana without
that was an illegal search um examples
like that
so if he could just pass a law that was
one thing but but
um you know actually sorry there
couldn't be even be lost for that
because they so clearly violated the
constitution even though
obviously he wouldn't have approved of
of those particular actions
sure uh he was also known as a talker
during oral arguments he asked asked a
lot of questions and clearly
sometimes though they weren't really
questions they were just arguments he
was making to his fellow justices now do
you think he went into most cases with
his mind made up
based on the briefs and the precedents
i'm not saying it's a bad thing but is
that usually the case
i think that the justices you know i
can't say for certain but my hunch is
that they often have go in with a pretty
good idea but i think for the most part
they they do ask
questions not just to not just to be
heard or not just to make arguments
but because they they want to really
engage with the arguments
that the lawyers are making in the
forward to this collection justice kagan
first of all very happy that she agreed
to write this beautiful forward but she
she says that she says just that that
you know dad would ask these questions
because he loved argument and kind of
loved
mixing it up it wasn't just kind of it
wasn't just for show though he did i
think you're right he was very kind of
an engaging speaker and
there was some study years ago that that
found he was the
he was the funniest justice by the
standards of
he drew the most laughed right um from
from the courtroom during oral arguments
which you know
obviously isn't the most important thing
to do but just shows how much he
he enjoyed that process did that love
for debate did it was it a two-way
street was
was he persuadable yeah absolutely and
that that's something justice kagan
mentions in her forward she she doesn't
say when she ever changed his mind but
but
uh says that yeah they changed each
other's minds at times
well christopher scalia it was great to
talk to you uh the book is called the
essential scalia
on the constitution the courts and the
rule of law chris scalia really good to
talk to you thanks so much
thanks so much i appreciate your time
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information
on your time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
an 80 year old holocaust survivor is
celebrating after beating covet 19.
my name is aaron rudislavsky i was born
in 1940
after my parents escaped from poland
in 1939 from hitler
we lived in russia for seven years and
then we moved to poland
to to see if anybody from 16
brothers and sisters of my parents left
alive but now all of them got murdered
by hitler and his wife rita came to the
u.s
in 1966 and eventually settled in
philadelphia
she says for two long months doctors
fought to keep her husband alive
he was intubated and was asleep for
close to 60 days
in an induced coma paralyzed
basically before he contracted covet 19
average says he was very active
i did i did sport six times a week
i was very active i
i did water skiing horseback riding
zip lining uh white water rafting
uh i did play tennis racquetball
personal training always on the go
so maybe this was a big thing he says
now he's fighting to get back to his
pre-coveted active lifestyle
this is my goal and it's my dream and
to be the same i used to be for the
disease he urges his fellow seniors
to keep moving anybody get up in age
don't ever stop moving
exercising doing sport i learned
from my sickness it's a bad one i don't
blame
i don't want anybody have that it's
really horrible
be strong and fight and
that's what you can do tanya j powers
fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind sitting outside on
an autumn morning it's chilly
autumn's here guys it's here
the other day our heat turned on
and i shut it off because the day before
we actually had our air conditioners
running
i feel like there should be at least a
week or two
where you have no climate control in
your house maybe it's the pioneer spirit
in me i want to experience that
autumn air it's chilly when you first
wake up in the morning but it's nice
i like autumn it's my favorite of the
seasons
i think it's responsible for the best
songs
you know there's plenty of spring and
summer songs but they're
i don't know they're springy they lack
depth
the autumn songs are not quite as bleak
as winter but they have a melancholy
feel
autumn in new york september song
the autumn leaves drift by my window
even
simon and garfunkel singing leaves that
are green turn to brown
says it all doesn't it guns and roses
even
november rain not quite a classic but a
good tune
autumns for halloween thanksgiving
football games
even the yard work is nice at first i
gotta say i prefer
raking the lawn to mowing it when i was
a kid we used to rake up a big pile of
leaves
and we'd dive into them we'd get a big
running start and just
belly flop into that pile
i tried that with my kids last year have
you tried diving into a pile of leaves
lately
it's not soft it's not soft at all
well here's wishing you a happy autumn
in new york or wherever you are this is
tom chalu
[Music]
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown rundown stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes